surrounded by stunning lakes and close
to two major ski resorts called the lane
is one of Idaho's Premier vacation
destinations it's also home to the
Roosevelt Inn
the Inn is a 16 bedroom converted
Schoolhouse owned and run by one of its
former students John Hoff
the Roosevelt Inn is the first hotel
I've ever actually owned I was up here
signing the papers and I called my wife
Tina and I say we now own the Roosevelt
town and all of a sudden I hear this
started crying I did not want to buy the
hotel but John really did I have told
John many times that he won't be cold in
the ground and I'm on my way home to
Kentucky
the Roosevelt Inn is not just hell for
Tina it's hell for the guests who have
to put up with the consequences of Jon's
eccentric Behavior sorry we're not
trying to be a pain yes you are I would
say that the hotel is struggling because
it's dated it's
old probably because it is old and the
food coming out of the Inns shoebox size
kitchen is as bad as the decor
oblivious to the problems John's
performance never stops I'll ask you
questions you'll give me answers I'll
ask questions you'll give answers and
I'll ask you questions you'll give me
answers as John is more focused on
playing dress-up how was that Watson
then I'm being an Innkeeper John refuses
to grow old gracefully it's Halloween
for John every day he loves to dress up
it's the cuss it's the bloody curse once
a month at the Roosevelt we put on a
murder mystery and dinner how's
everything going in here for you bye
I basically do everything uh you want to
finish making up this bed and I'll do
the bathroom okay great I feel my dad
doesn't appreciate my mom my mom works
three times harder than my dad does
there are times that I'll come in and
she's out busy doing something and he's
sitting on the couch reading a book as
the business has suffered so has John
and Tina's relationship we actually had
to go through marriage counseling I
don't think John understands the
sacrifice I've made unless I can get
this place on the road to recovery John
and Tina will lose everything if I lose
the Roosevelt I don't just lose my job I
lose my home I become unemployed and
homeless in one fell swoops dang it I
don't think we're gonna pull out of this
one
I'm here in curdor Lane Idaho I
seriously hope this place is better than
the other shitholes I've stayed in oh my
God
look at that they say all publicity is
good publicity but the billboard that
old-fashioned
I'm not so sure you're [__] joking at
him come on
the Roosevelt Inn Bed and Breakfast it's
like something at The Addams Family
Roosevelt School the place looks Grim
from the outside
hello welcome to the Roosevelt good to
see you I recognize that voice you're
Gordon Ramsay okay oh my God look at
those chairs there are they from school
they are those came out of the first
grade classroom oh look you almost fit
uh
Soldier
first impression for the outside
it smells like [__] as well what is that
is that did the dog do a oh boy I sure
hope not oh
yes man Jesus this is her dining room
who's the chef here I saw a billboard of
a guy with the most hideous hat on
covered in trees and like this six foot
hats
kind of grown into jean-pierrezimad
French chef at the Roosevelt because
you're in Coeur d'Alene is a French
named Tom noon also we must cook
fabulous food above this outfit
now you'll see uh School photos yes down
the hallway here and these are of kids
that went to school here at the
Roosevelt and the ones with the arrows
pointing at the really cute adorable
little boy that's me of course because I
went to school here oh you went to my
Elementary School
who wants to live in their old school
it's like getting a detention That Never
Ends the guests get to hang out down
here with the dogs and watch TV you are
kidding me
you can't smell those dogs oh yes I can
the dogs actually believe it or not
Gordon
are one of the highlights here
now you're sounding deluded
what's next our little Ballroom or our
multi-purpose room oh come on Rohan
you're not supposed to be in this room
don't you think this place could at
least had some form of makeover well
sadly Gordon we renovated this room four
years ago
this is new stop now this room looks
like it was last decorated in 1908 not
2008. how much do you spend on this
fifty four thousand fifty four thousand
five four
not 5400 54 000. I know lovely huh
Christopher and does it generate money
no I can't believe anyone would want to
rent in that space it's hideous I'm
dying to have a look upstairs it can't
get any worse it could get worse and
what's your uh occupancy across the year
probably around mid-20s 20 across the
board ouch I'm amazed you find it so
funny this is your room
okay what's with all the pink it's like
someone threw up strawberry milkshake
all over the place my room has two
levels
eat as bad as the other oh everything
looks like we're in a time I mean it is
so dated
so my room how much are you pay to stay
in here uh 319
319 bloody hell I'm speechless
[Laughter]
13 year old Decor 319 a night can I ask
you something fire away why do you think
everything's a big joke
because you're very critical I'm here to
get this place right but what I don't
understand is how blase you are
situation I am going to give you the
truth and if you don't like that then
I'm out of it what do you want me to do
I'm angry and punch you you want to
punch me
maybe I do want to punch you a little
bit but I can become physically very
very violent and have in the past people
get hurt
John John
you can't just walk away where are you
going
[Music]
Since I checked into Idaho's Roosevelt
Inn I've been unimpressed by the
horrible Decor what's with all the paint
it's like someone's vomited everywhere
and the dated event space that smells
like wet dog the dogs actually are one
of the highlights
but the biggest problem here is the
owner John who seems to think it's funny
that he's in is a disgrace the only time
he stopped laughing was when I
confronted him with how bad things
really are here what I don't understand
is how blase you are the situation
jump you don't drive away
while John hides from the truth
downstairs
I'm gonna have a closer look at my room
that's when the rugs on the floor for
just gross look at the dust on there
most disgusting of all [__] is the dust
magnet hanging over my pillows
[Music]
how long has that thing been up there
how
let me out
I hope I'll get a sense of what's really
going on here from John's wife Tina
Gordon this is my lovely wife how are
you I'm stressed out
what hotel were you winning before this
I was running a dental office I worked
in a dental office I wasn't running
anything except my home so why would you
go from sort of teeth to Hotel because
he bought a hotel
so you bought the hotel it was my
negotiation
you negotiated you both bought it yes
yes willingly or unwillingly unwillingly
I was very happy and content with the
life that we had so when John told me
that we were buying the Roosevelt I
burst into tears how much did you buy
for seven hundred thousand seven
where's your house now what do you live
in we live up in the attic
this is my help I have had terrible
experiences here business experience
financial hardship everything's just
Fallen apart here for me
you seem serious you seem joking it's
almost like you're playing at it it is
kind of an entertainment though
to a certain degree at 1.1 million
dollars that's an expensive
entertainment well yeah I didn't realize
it was this bad how's the relationship I
think we're in a rough place
we went through marriage counseling what
was that four or five years ago
because of this business oh yeah and
still working together seven days a week
yes 24 7. I'm ready for something to
change I'm ready for anything at this
point I just feel like I'm
gonna suffocate let me get my uh bag
unpacked and I'll uh I'll catch up with
you later thank you Tina looks ready to
bail out and all John can do is laugh he
thinks being over a million dollars in
debt is entertainment I think this
marriage is in as much trouble as the
end clearly in denial but more
importantly
man that won't man up and take
responsibility
[Music]
I've been told that tonight the
Roosevelt Inn is holding a murder
mystery dinner it's an event they host
once a month I have a feeling it's gonna
be hard to forget
head of your head on into there I'll get
you all checked in ready to go you look
fabulous we usually always have a lot of
fun with this we're going to continue to
have fun with this are you dressing that
this evening I play the part of Sherlock
Holmes old man you're playing an
Englishman I am playing an Englishman
and I even have the pipe to go with it
I've studied this accent long and hard
in fact mine is better than your British
accent
actually don't know where Gordon got his
accent he obviously doesn't practice it
very much mine is far more authentic
than his is
absolutely yes wow
well John Prince is around a Sherlock
Holmes I wonder what Tina does during
these events
oh my god what have you got on this is
crazy
it's not a mystery night sir it's gone
from an end to little house and Prairie
I mean obviously it'll be my job this
evening to cook your dinner so while
John gets to play Sherlock Holmes his
wife is stuck in the kitchen wake up
John this is not the 1800s anymore John
definitely liked dressing up more for
the murder mysteries because he's not in
the hot kitchen he's out there Hamming
it up with the guests playing Sherlock
Holmes okay
right
um
to make all this is a little bit bizarre
slightly weird I wonder if this event
even makes any money is this profitable
it is profitable
yeah it's a lot of work I mean we made
2008 200 for all this work and are they
all staying oh no what's the locals you
know when they come for a murder mystery
they usually don't do an overnight
clearly tonight's about feeding John's
ego not filling his bank account oh well
that that could explain it then yeah oh
here now oh I would I say oh my [__]
god hell come to me sir ladies and
gentlemen it appears the game is afoot
you know their goal with the murder
mysteries has always been to get people
in but I'm not feeling the rooms what's
the point
[Music]
and I would have called away with it too
if it wasn't for you and your meddling
guests
well there you have it brilliant of all
of you
thank goodness that's over it's time to
find out from John what on Earth he
thinks he's doing
sit down you must be shattered I'm tired
I bet you are sick of fork in me it's
Matt was it mad yeah
you're in the kitchen busting your ass
off working hard to serve all those
people and Don you were out prancing
around like a sort of actor the thespian
thing it's an inn it's not a theater but
you seem to enjoy it you have to force
yourself to like doing it I mean it's on
stage for three hours and
the problems at the Roosevelt are
Elementary can I just never work with
you on your own oh sure
this place is sinking because John
refuses to take anything seriously you
love being an Entertainer don't you dare
tell me that that is hardly this whole
[__] thing was put together for your
fantasy well that's kind of what this
night is it is entertainment we put on a
show
you're pretending to be Cheryl at home
and upstairs we're empty you're in the
[__] financially we're in Ruins and if
you put the same amount of effort into
filling this place just one
room book tonight would have made more
profit than the whole murder mystery and
all that work that went into it I mean
this is insane and you prance around
like some [__] idiot while your wife
is slaving away in the kitchen do you
have any care in the world apart for
yourself
you get a psychology degree oh when I go
you come and tell me what's wrong with
me here we go you obviously think you
are psychologist denial again no I'm not
in denial I just don't know what you
want it's only your own [__]
stupidity to why we're in the [__] this
far well that is probably true so then
man up and act responsible
[Music]
you need to grow up and stop running
away from the truth
joke
at Idaho's Roosevelt Inn
house and last night proved to me that
owner John needs to stop dressing up
wait till I get going and start growing
up you prance around like some [__]
idiot and take some responsibility for
the problems at the end it's only your
own [__] stupidity to why we're in
the [__] I'm done with that but John
didn't want to listen just talk to my
hand you know oh what a [__] idiot
today I'm gonna have another go at
getting through to him before he heads
into the kitchen to prepare lunch
you're losing money you're on this
treadmill of mistake after mistake we
may be in a elementary school but you're
not a child and I would really wish if
you stop acting like one quickly is that
possible
[Music]
show me what you got
can you get that I don't want to cook
for gardening I mean first of all he's
got a huge Eagle of his own so you know
nothing anybody else does is going to be
any good I don't even want to cook him a
thing how are we doing over here what a
spread that I'm in town and the dining
room is full we're all having the same
five core set menu cooked in the Inn's
Tiny Kitchen
[Music]
thank you
that's Gastly
what the watery bits what's that
um that's probably the tomato juice
unless it's condensation from the shrimp
condensation was it Frozen yes
yeah warm it's a sad looking shrimp
that's not a good style
I will take that for you and everyone
else seems to be hating it too how can
you [__] up
okay here's Gordon's pecan crusted a
salmon is it fresh salmon Frozen that
has to be the saddest looking plate of
salmon anywhere in North America tonight
[Music]
seasoning is triple very dry would you
like me a ticket for you yes please I'm
sorry I'll Take Everything
tastes great to me
I'm gonna kill him I just want Gordon to
take a long walk off a short pier I want
him to fall into a very deep pit
so he can't get out
this is pathetic conjun cook anything
he can cook an egg could you ask him
just a homemade egg sure thing it can't
possibly mess up a soft-boiled egg can
he soft-boiled egg
okay what soft boiled egg what
I'm just like going
wow
[Music]
I'll make my own egg cup I can't help
I was wrong is this really happening he
can't even boil a [__] egg
[__] thing's still got feathers on it
could have probably cooked out another
two minutes
I am absolutely ready to boot Gordon
Ramsay out of my hand
[Music]
fire away buddy are you having a laugh
at your family's expense no
big tall hat big jacket and you can't
boil a [__] egg donut fried egg
you want french toast too how about some
pancakes but [__] are you doing
you don't care do you I do care you're a
[__] joke
those are what we refer to as fighting
words gutsy thing to do especially in a
kitchen full of sharp knives it has
never been a joke for me ever come play
at my school I'm the Headmaster you're
acting like an absolute idiot no but
you're in my house that's right I'm
disgusted at your performance your big
problem is you can't handle the truth
you don't like hearing it you don't even
know me
think about your wife you're in to 1.1
million dollars of debt you're forcing
her to live in Hell she's telling me
that I just think over the last 13 years
but what you've [__] done
and not to you it's every outstanding
behind you I'm tired of hearing that I
don't need it anymore
screw it I really don't care if he
leaves [__] man
I had a horrible night's sleep on the
couch because I couldn't sleep in my bed
I really need a hot shower
oh [__] [__] you know this water's
freezing I need to open John's eyes but
he walks out every time things get
difficult so I've got another plan have
you got two minutes we do there's
something I'd like to show you both in
my uh my room oh crap
what now what's wrong
now please consider help
there's the jury and they're going to
hang us clearly you recognize some of
your guests from the past six months we
do I think feedback is critical First
Impressions walking through the door a
lot of decorations
I'd like to go on to the food
um the general consensus
it wasn't the value that we paid
honestly show of hands how many of you
would return and stay here again please
none of our guests would return
I'm kind of speechless I I didn't expect
this I thought it was I thought we were
better than that that's the most
valuable information you've had in 13
years I thought we were a lot better
than this and that that is uh a view
that is changing you've got to put
yourself in the guest position
you know you give me feedback on
everything you've seen and experienced
but there's something I'd like to point
out that none of you see
please
would you be so kind to put a pair of
these on please
oh my gosh and let's just get
any more terrible things I don't think
so last season
this black light is going to show up any
bodily fluids
let's start with the uh the pillow Sean
it's there
oh my God like someone urinated on it
disgusting
if you think that's bad
[Music]
this kind of stuff hasn't been weeks
that's that's years
[Music]
absolutely hideous horrified disgusted
grossed out
kind of want to go vomit
so you kind of trust that things are
going to be you have the right and you
you have that this is just as bad as it
can possibly be I mean I'm disgusted I
laughs how does that make you feel don't
make me actually feel sick
tonight thought I took a shower but now
I'm gonna
I'll let you go thank you
thank you very much thank you
this is me I mean I've put my heart and
soul into this
[Music]
you won't listen to me and John just
laughs at every problem
[Music]
I'm worried about Tina hearing from the
guests and seeing those stains seem to
hit her pretty hard Tia yes have you got
two sets
foreign
against the wall with John I don't know
what we do is not perfect but I thought
what we did was better than that
he's got to get out of this bubble
he's an Innkeeper
but he's constantly joking and shrugging
responsibility and now he has to start
looking at himself
the thing that probably bothers me the
most is John just refuses to understand
my need to have my part of the dream I
don't like living and eating and
breathing my work 24 7 and never ever
having a place to go that I can get away
yeah they're not happy
I'm not happy no
I'm not
at the end of the day I usually lay down
the bed and I know this is what I wanted
and I'd leave here tomorrow if I could
leave here tomorrow I'm Ray just walk
away from this and just forget it I'm
gonna leave I want to get out of here
and go away
Khan give up 13 years of being unhappy
is not immobile it's a mountain if you
have a voice you've got to stand up you
absolutely have the right to be happy
I guess maybe I needed somebody to say
you have a right to be happy
so that was good thank you
I'll see you later okay I promise you
I'll make a difference and I mean that
last night John's wife Tina was at a
breaking point I feel happy
no and I'd leave here tomorrow if I
could leave here tomorrow I'll detective
I realized how bad things really are
here and I promise to make things better
because Tina truly deserves to be happy
good morning Daddy good morning how are
you
I'm I'm here you're here
um let's catch up let's get out of this
little cubby hole okay
um maybe downstairs
I can't believe that John and Tina have
spent sixty thousand dollars on a
ballroom that they never used and smells
like dog looking at this Inn there's a
huge missed opportunity the potential of
this room is extraordinary and this has
to be used as a way to get people into
the bedrooms upstairs and make money
exactly how often do you use this room
twice a month oh no that's crazy it is
have you ever thought about employing a
wedding planner to actually book this
place out I have one I'm working with
been working with her for just about a
year now I don't pay her a salary it's
her wedding if we score a wedding we
both get paid so she's motivated to sell
it
for me it's a big missed opportunity you
know once you've held an amazing wedding
and you've got such great feedback it
just spreads okay this is what I want to
see I'll see you later yeah thank you
this does not Stack Up
I'm gonna go meet the wedding planner
because
it must be something that John and Tina
aren't telling me
hello how are you nice to me where
should we start well you want to come on
over and we'll have a seat yes come on
over
the Roosevelt um what would you say the
key problems it's dated it's it's hard
to sell 10 day old bread right you know
braids are young they're sophisticated
they're on their phones they're seeing
with the rest of the world is doing you
know a big thing with selling the
ballroom is the colors that only matches
a tiny percentage you can either go
burgundy Ivory or navy blue and those
colors are so dated anyways it's
terrible and then you walk downstairs
and the smell I had one girl literally
say I've got to go upstairs the smell is
going to make me sick
John doesn't
strike me as someone that I'd want to
put my wedding in his hands as a host
how is he we have had some issues last
summer with him coming out and dancing
at the guest wedding yes like ballroom
dancing or it was more like Macarena
type line dancing style oh my God I mean
how awkward was that it was mortifying
if you just bear with me whilst I make
some changes because I mean you are the
key to their success going forward would
you give them one more chance
I'm in thank you good to see you too
good to see you thank you thank you Don
now that Misty is on board to help the
Roosevelt I'm gonna make one last
attempt to see if John is ready to
change
how you feeling
[Music]
I'm not here to hurt your feelings John
but you have
a huge defense mechanism I have an
attitude I want to help but you are a
very tough stubborn
selfish individual to get through to
yeah it hurts it's not a sign of
weakness to put your hand up and ask for
help
[Music]
and I don't want to put heads
I don't want about hats either
Gordon I've got two options here I can
close up the business walk away from it
give it to the bank
the other option is
I know I've done this to myself I've
done this to my wife
I've got to find a way to get out of it
this has been your dream your ambition
and she just followed suit you're
correct you have one amazing loyal lady
there I don't deserve her
I'm a pig sometimes there's just no
doubt about it
yeah
trying to change that she's not the one
that should be suffering because of what
I did and
considered that in yours
let's start making this place better I
need you committed
I want the help I want to make this work
[Music]
now that John's finally turned the
corner I'm a pig sometimes trying to
change that it's time to sit down with
Tina and get to the heart of their
relationship I'm so pleased that we've
got the place that we can start making
steps in the right direction but this is
a family run in and you need your time
out and you need to cut
your dear lady slack you need to learn
The Importance of Being a happy couple
what have you got to say now we've been
so wrapped up in this
and everything we do that
we just don't even know where to where
to go with romance anymore it's like
I'm so self-consumed
with all of this
just the ability to just have a
conversation with you understanding my
my feelings I have wishes and Ambitions
there are things that
are important to me
they're vitally important to me you'd
have to support that if you're not
prepared to support each other in each
other's roles then it's never ever going
to work you need to be happy together I
want to know what your dreams are again
I haven't heard a Dream from you in
years
I don't even know what your dreams are I
don't know what my dreams are anymore
I've I've
quit dreaming I want you to start
dreaming again
then I want you to share those dreams
with me
because I love you
I know you do told all my girls they
were princesses
are too
I haven't treated you much like royalty
I do feel that Gordon has helped John
appreciate me more and see what's going
on inside of here
should matter to him
now that they're talking the game I want
to give Tino John a lesson in something
else they've not done well for a long
time wow cooking
many in Country Hotel it's all about
comfort and what I learned immediately
from you is that you're trying way too
hard you've got a shoe box of a kitchen
that you can't swing a cat in you should
be cooking five course meals in there
okay you're not a chef no you shouldn't
be on a billboard that shouldn't be a
delicious home-cooked meal that's all
I'd expect to see that's all I expect to
smell when you come through that door so
put together
a list of dishes for the whole week
something you can cook in one pot
fabulous let it cook itself really
fabulous these are my recipes I'm proud
of them don't start improvising change
you just follow them they will work half
an hour to get the chili on yeah
fabulous sweet nobody comes here John
and Tina expecting a five course meal
the food was an amazing discovery that
it could be so simple so easy so
delicious I'm glad that Gordon is in my
kitchen tomorrow's a new dawn for the
Roosevelt and my goodness are we going
to turn the page
my team worked all night to bring the
hotel into the 21st century now it's
time to reveal the new Roosevelt Inn
good morning good morning
or spring in your step John how you
feeling wonderful good let's go okay
come here come in come in please okay 16
rooms 32 guests this hotel should be
full welcome to your new honeymoon suite
wow
[Laughter]
[Music]
we were literally two centuries back in
time with what we were doing in these
rooms and we are suddenly into now today
it's
John and Tina I'd like you both to go
upstairs
[Music]
very pretty
a room that will be great for room
service to have a bit of romance oh this
is just truly beautiful now
we're selling those rooms the big asset
that was underused in many ways was
downstairs truly that's been a huge
come with me now let me show you the new
stunning Roosevelt wedding space
I thought we had something that would be
viable to help build our business and it
wasn't it was dragging it down oh
oh
[Music]
okay this is stunning this is amazing
absolutely amazing
[Music]
this is stunning oh my gosh this is the
direction we need to be going in this is
the next step up and I am extremely
grateful and I don't want to see a dog I
dog's hair I dogs chew anywhere in this
space understood now this room should
Propel this business to Greater Heights
it has to be your biggest marketing tool
because when you've got the wedding
books the guests should book every room
upstairs
this space and the revenue it can bring
into the Roosevelt could definitely be
the game changer that we've been looking
for I'd like to point your attention to
those wonderful plates and all the
glassware on the tables
that's a special gift to you worth fifty
thousand dollars no way really
you've now got
you know a solo Foundation to host the
most amazing wedding
now there's someone I'd like you to meet
hey please
you may recognize this lady
look at our new space
I hope Misty's gonna give us a second
chance what strikes you now walking
through that room what's the first thing
that hits you it's just it's natural
it's it's modern it's what the brides
are looking for they're sophisticated
they're young this is what they want and
does it show sort of Versatility in a
way that it can be adapted to suit
different colors absolutely we can put
any color in this room and it'll be
wonderful yay this is gonna sell itself
how does it smell it smells wonderful
now here's the good news she is prepared
to give you one more chance to become
curder lens number one venue for hosting
weddings one more surprise John and Tina
Missy's not just here to visit the
Roosevelt
is hosting a wedding tonight tonight
[Music]
owners of the Roosevelt Inn John and
Tina have come a long way from when I
first met them personally because I love
you and professionally I want to make
this work I've just surprised them with
a true test for their business the
Roosevelt is hosting a wedding tonight
wow
tonight when Gordon said we had a
wedding tonight instant gut clenching
terror you're gonna be cooking serving
just simple elegant food
yeah good luck
[Music]
are you a bride hello welcome let me
just take you ladies up to the room all
right go on in ladies
oh my dress guess we're just starting to
ride
[Applause]
[Music]
I gave John and Tina a couple of simple
but delicious wedding recipes that they
could cook in their tiny kitchen and
that I knew the guests would love this
evening is going to be huge for us
you're feeling that that really wound up
sense inside yourself and it's like holy
cow
foreign
s downstairs upstairs in the kitchen
John and Tina are proving they are there
for each other when it matters
I give you all that I am I give you all
that I am and you may kiss your bride
[Music]
you're that side on this side and we go
bang
okay ladies let's go grab them and go
grab them and go
for the first time ever the food at the
Roosevelt is putting a smile on people's
faces
try and bunch them up a little bit it
just look so much neater including
Tina's breathe and talk and okay I've
got this awesome we're a nice rotation
here
John and Tina are a great team when they
communicate properly
I think the buzz they get from tonight
will encourage them to keep working on
their relationship how you doing we're
rocking along here
I love it plates are going away
it's the best thing I've ever had well
done okay how'd you feel
where's John well done oh thank you
first time you've actually cooked yes
yeah from scratch for an amazing wedding
well done both of you thank you
it's been a great night thanks to John
and Tina's teamwork you guys did it even
ahead of schedule
you can do this I'm really hoping that
our future with Misty and our wedding
business just goes through the roof
time to go I'm gonna be a bit sad to
leave this place I think John
and Tina done a bloody good job tonight
and more importantly I think the whole
wedding has opened their eyes the huge
potential they've got here
tonight the Roosevelt is fully booked
for the first time in years and the Inn
is back on course for Success it's been
a hell of a week yes tonight proved that
you both can pull this off once we got
the system going it went very well stick
together
all right we'll do it like Lou you've
got every chance now good luck you can
have a happy
thank you so much
take care of yourself thank you to not
sneak downstairs to that dance floor not
even head in that direction no nice
foreign
[Music]
so gorgeous oh my God oh there's an
upstairs thank you Gordon Ramsay for
giving us this opportunity this
experience obviously is not meant to be
easy but in the end
worth it so thank you very much it was
nice to say goodbye to him tonight and I
look forward to seeing him again
actually
Longview Washington voted one of
America's prettiest towns is home to a
Pacific Northwest Jewel the Monticello
Hotel built in 1923 this historic
building is currently celebrating its
90th anniversary but unlike cheese and
good wine some things do not get better
with age
gosh
and Philip loving buzz and I'm the owner
of the Monticello Hotel I wanted to own
the hotel since I was eight years old my
mother worked here when I was very young
and I remember all the cocktail
waitresses and how beautiful they were
and wanted to be a part of it some might
say the story of how Philip lovingfoss
obtained the hotel is almost too good to
be true others might call it a fairy
tale Philip was a bartender here he fell
in love with the owner Annabelle Jewel I
was in my early 30s and I first started
going together and she was in her
mid-60s
they were married and when Annabelle
passed away all of her assets
were given to Philip he inherited the
Monticello Hotel
it's all pretty
with his inheritance Philip has been
living the good life with his girlfriend
and general manager Ginger who's also 30
years senior TJ but despite the owner's
fabulous wealth the staff are underpaid
I still make minimum wage and I've been
here 12 years
flaunts his wealth in front of us don't
flaunt it in our face when we're all
wondering do we put gas in the car or do
we buy groceries this is [__] unreal
he's probably got 150 000 worth of
diamonds on his right arm 10 karat
diamond ring on his left finger he
walked through the kitchen one day and
and somebody broke a glass and he said
oh would I lose a stone I mean really
how [__] arrogant I want to say [__]
you
while Philip and ginger have been
enjoying their wealth the hotel has been
terribly neglected
cigarette Burns
seriously that is so gross
all the way down the hall around the
corner inside the beautiful historic
Monticello Hotel there were only four
Suites and then there are countless
rooms stuffed with Philip and Ginger's
crap instead of guests
with only four guest bedrooms available
in the main Hotel most guests are
unwittingly given rooms in the so-called
North Wing which is a characterless
1960s shoebox Motel Next Door I was
hoping to stay in the hotel not
something you feel like stand right now
and having been ignored for years the
hotel is not generating any new business
with a rapidly dwindling client base
where's Mary she's not here with us
it's once glamorous hotel has major
problems
but Philip's problem may be the biggest
it is no big secret that Philip drinks
film will come in here drunk good job
chick good job in front of all the staff
and it's just an embarrassing mess
[Music]
the day before I arrived in Longview
things reach crisis point
I was pulled over
and they charged me with a DUI I was a
place under arrest they booked me in the
Cowles County jail and yesterday morning
I was released it's an unfortunate
situation
thank you you guys have a good night
this hotel its staff and the community
deserve better
Phil talk about closing it if Gordon
isn't able to save this place for us
um 50 people will be out of jobs and
Phil will be on his yacht in Seattle
drunk
this place is a gem that needs to be
preserved it's the heart of Longview
this town needs the Monticello
[Music]
gorgeous that place is massive look at
all those rooms for guests finally
somewhere nice to stay I feel sorry for
the crappy Motel Next Door I'm amazed
that place is still open right next to a
big hotel like that my God
yeah
one of those beautiful cars it must be a
car show on
oh no somebody having a laugh Hotel Hell
lady's nine who the [__] can't spell
part-time housekeeper I can't do
anything worse to advertise on the
outside of your hotel
[Music]
good morning good morning and first name
is Vanessa Vanessa I see you having a
classic car show today no those all
belong to our owner Phillip no stop they
do
they belong to the owner what's with the
plate that's like Hotel Hell on one of
the plates yes
is that for me I'm not sure if you did
it for your
the employer of the month 2010. you know
it's
2013. I do yes are the staff that bad
there hasn't been a more recent employee
of the month last I heard actually he
was in jail holy crap we have so many
great employees it's ridiculous that
we're not recognized more than we are
here's your card and here is your room
code you're in room 220. uh we show me
the way or oh sure if you'd like shall
we please if you follow me I've got that
we're going outside yes okay just across
here so you have to go out to get back
up again yes
and 220 right here
um but this is not the Hotel this is our
North Wing Motel
why in the [__] would I want to stay in
there
I'd rather stay in there next door okay
than in this dump I'm sorry people want
to stay in the hotel they don't want to
stay in the Cracker Box driving up here
didn't expect to be put in a motel no I
understand and I'm I am sorry
all right it's just right over here
thank you you're welcome let's see how
sofas hidden
hitty sofa like that
oh my God it gets worse in here this bed
is this auntie uh no the rooms are
furnished completely with stuff from
Phillip and Ginger's home oh dear this
mattress from the house yes
bring a mattress from your house into
your hotel I wouldn't they charge 250 a
night for that mattress I don't even
know what to say about it when they get
new stuff they bring old stuff here
there's some storage rooms that are full
of old furniture where the storage
places
jeez it's like a sweet just full of crap
it's like a dumping crab
there's more too wow you are kidding me
not oh my God look at this
I wish I was kidding it's like a hoarder
it's just junk everywhere I don't
understand the hotel owner that would
dump half a ship in the hotel rooms and
not rent them out Gordon was pretty
appalled that the state of the storage
rooms how much crap there was in there
it's just a big [__] waste I
appreciate it thank you
wow this place is so disappointing the
biggest highlight so far is the drive up
the minute you step inside it's just
bizarre I can't wait to meet the owner
and find out what the hell is going on
in his head
foreign
I've just arrived at the Monticello
Hotel in Longview Washington and I'm
shocked to discover that there are only
four rooms for guests in this Grand
Place While others are being used for
storage oh my God it's like a hoarder
it's just junk everywhere I've got to
meet the owner and the general manager
and figure out what else is wrong with
this place
nice to see you very nice to see you and
welcome to the Monticello thank you what
a gorgeous place from the outside thank
you how are you good so you're Ginger
yes this is my significant other hello
there you go is that true
it's true wow look at that bling look it
looks like a Super Bowl ring
do you have it for me
um I thought it was a car Fair here so
someone told me they're yours where am I
amazes
let's go to the lounge
did you always want to own a hotel ever
since I was a little kid I wouldn't go
in this house and what's the building
worth now I mean probably three and five
million it's extraordinary I inherited
it real estate yes and if you don't mind
me asking what was that the tune of
is the hotel making money or losing
money
I've been carrying it how much you're
losing 30 to 35 000 a month oh lose it
for 400 Grand a year
that's insane there's lots of sleepless
nights for me how are we losing so much
money being taken advantage of I know
that who's taking advantage the kitchen
staff for sure
they wait and leave the clock
to think you're gonna get paid for hours
that you're not working they can't do
that to you
I think Gordon's going to have
difficulties with my employees I don't
see them as team players at all if this
place was taken away what would it mean
to you devastated it would be equivalent
to a death oh geez I started here in
1973. this has been a huge part of my
life
well let's give an Insight let me tell
you
um Ginger nice to see you then very nice
likewise thank you thank you
thank you so much it's terrible to hear
that Philip and ginger I've been taking
advantage of by their staff when they
clearly care so much I really hope I can
help them sort their employers out oh
hello good evening how are you I'm fine
I'm Debbie Debbie to see I have a table
for you right over here now how long we
been here I have been here 12 years wow
seriously 12 years yes
um right what would you recommend I
recommend
our crab and artichoke dip okay let's
get for one of those all right
Phillips triple Tower yes what's that
it's a three-tier Tower of three
different appetizers and is his name big
enough on the menu there obviously
suffering from small man syndrome it's
good for that and then the bassinet
ravioli let's try that all right thanks
nice to see you
so the appetizers first please okay well
I'm feeling really nervous about cooking
for Gordon they're all [__] froze
together most of the food is
pre-packaged or canned or frozen because
Ginger and Phillip are running this
place like real misers they uh Pinch A
Penny on every corner
this is our crab and artichoke dip it's
served with deep fried pita bread and um
is it fresh crab or canned frozen chili
and crab frozen chili and crab correct
[__] snot dip
I mean it's like a dish ready for one of
Phillip's girlfriends no teeth oh God
it's got a sour taste to it I don't know
what it is no Jesus
he felt it tasted sour it always got
that taste of me I don't like it
you are kidding me
off the tower this is the tower this is
the tower oh my God holy Mackle so
it's like something you should have in
your [__] Garden not in your
restaurant are those shrimp are they
fresh or are they frozen they're frozen
they're frozen damn
[Music]
I'm here they're teriyaki beef tips
Jesus
my sauce is hideous
and they're tough
chew
and that middle one's another portion of
snot dip I'll skip that well
unfortunately for the chef he doesn't
get to dictate his own menu
his own menu he does not
shall we might be careful
so Philips dictating the menu I suppose
if his staff can't be trusted to clock
in and out they can't be trusted to
choose the food
feedback on that the meat is too tough
the sauce tastes weird he can tell it's
not homemade
it's just Ramses
and it is the meat is too tough yeah
it's getting the full picture and that's
just what I wanted
right I feel very good about it I am
very disappointed with Dan's food it's
horrible I just hope that Gordon sees
the problems with his staff
ravioli
I'm dreading bringing this dish out to
him right now the butternut rapidly
thank you thank you who made the uh
raviolis I don't know the name of the
manufacturer manufacturer correct so the
rubbery's aren't even made either they
are not made here oh Jesus they're
packaged
it's Dreadful like a mouthful of sugar
every time
oh dear thank you though wow
frozen crab frozen shrimp pre-packaged
ravioli it's more like eating a badly
Renault folks home than a decent
restaurant
obviously from a package we all do that
one was coming
I think there's a better way that there
are a kitchen can function than it's
functioning right now I see this blatant
neglect
um tell me about Phillips management
style well when he's sober I get along
with him just fine
[Music]
when he's drinking I avoid him at all
costs does he drink a lot on sites he
does on a scale of one to turn how bad
is he drinking now at 10. this week he
was arrested
for what DUI
you are [__] kidding me I'm not
kidding oh my God I want to see the
hotel owner jailed jailed he was kept
overnight in jail bloody hell
why would he not tell me that well it
just happened hours ago Phillips in
denial he doesn't take responsibility
for his drinking problem and I felt he
Gordon needed to know
[Music]
um why don't you ask the chef to come
out of the dining room I'd like to meet
him and bring Philip and ginger as well
thank you
he would like to see you all in the
dining room
I'm lots of words Chef that was Dreadful
I don't think anything was fresh it
takes extra time to do things homemade
yeah naturally we're on a timer stream
what ask how many hours they get in a
week or whatever and they got to scrape
her out my prep cook gets 20 hours a
week
that's not enough time to make fresh
food is that why all the food's Frozen I
mean I get cut carrots or cut celery in
the bag I get the boiled eggs in a bag
done peeled you buy in boiled eggs yes
I played the safe card and
purchase most of it prepared you played
the safe cart we can't even boil a
[__] egg in here Philip if you care
about quality you need to pay people to
prep fresh food not buy it in there are
times uh through January February where
I'd have 12 16 hours a week a week yeah
how'd you survive three hours a day
not very well but do you have a family
yes I do damn seven kids
this is insane
you can't run this hotel like a miser
if I sold [__]
and put it into the kitchen budget to
function for the next 12 months the
chefs can do their job
and speaking of cars why you tell me
about this
[Music]
I'm at the Monticello Hotel in Longview
Washington oh my God I want to see the
hotel I don't know jailed jailed and
I've just discovered that the hotel
owner has a drinking problem so bad that
just one day before I arrived he was
arrested for drunk driving
can I have a word with the owner please
yes
what's going on
truthfully I don't know
have you had a drink today no
yes you have
your staff
tell me that you have a drinking problem
no
and yet you've just been busted
DUI
Ginger
does your boyfriend have a drinking
problem
he does like his locations
I'm pissed off that you couldn't even
say hey Gordon can I have a word God no
I fully intended on having a
conversation all over the newspaper
I'm aware of that who owned this place
me so when are you gonna step up I'm
your Gordon I'm engaged if you can't be
honest with yourself
[Music]
the facts are starting to become clear
the problem here isn't the staff it's
the owner you have
um room service we do not
no room service in a hotel this size
that's not the only unpleasant surprise
yes check in and just like me they think
they're going to get a room in a
historic gem but instead they're placed
in the motel
I don't think I could shower in this I
wonder if we can ask for a different
room in this example
and a fettuccine Alfredo's ready and
during dinner service most of the guests
are over the age of 17. there clearly
hasn't been any Buzz about this place in
decades yes sir that's not a prime rib
should be a little moisture in there
shouldn't it well I can go I can go and
check and see if there's another income
back there down yeah do we have another
a moist one please be juicy it is
Flynn will you do this no no all of a
suddenly he's involved
because I'm here
I'm sorry strawberry daiquiri
I can't believe Philip is put on a show
for me well if you want to know the
truth about a drinker ask the bartender
grants what is going on tonight it's
like a comedy of air is here you're
welcome
no no what does Philip normally do at
the hotel he does drink quite a bit
wow and on average a day how many drinks
would you make a day during the day
sometimes four or five and then it jumps
into the evening
could come up to uh seven eight
I had him cut off of a new one oh wow
wow no wonder things are on the slide
with Philip drinking that much I've got
to get him to tell me the truth
this monstrous hotel has been running
rudderless there's no one at the helm
and you're pretending all of a sudden
I'm busy I'm making some time lifting
because I'm here I I just no sad because
you're here we don't normally do this
stuff this is what I normally do you're
calling your staff Liars I would say so
if they say that I'm not out here
helping them every time I walk in this
building I would call them [__] Liars
I can just wave a [__]
[__] My Places run into the ground
[Music]
with dinner service over
I'm gonna get Philip and his staff
together so I can finally get to the
truth
[Music]
is that normal what I witnessed tonight
is Philip always here
does Philip always expedite the [__]
hot plate no no
we need somebody to expedite we're
understaffed and if we get busy then we
can't give good service and those people
will not come back a person can't
shortcut like that because of this place
the business being strangled yeah it's
been strangled by the owner
why are we pretending I'm doing a good
job of pretending then this is what I do
every time that you come in here this is
what you do I do not run food down to
your bar for the last couple nights
let's talk about the elephant in the
room shall we
when Phillip's drinking he behaves one
or two different ways either he's jovial
and likes to giggle and have a good time
or if finances are in arrears that we
hear about how much everything costs you
and you were going to close the doors
it's stressful it's not easy to come to
work with someone threatening us all the
time that the doors are going to be
closed please don't look at me like that
Phillip because you do do this to us
that's [__] you need to do the truth
you have told us over and over and over
again that you're just gonna I may I may
have said that twice
twice you have to come in here regularly
and say I'm going to close the doors if
we keep lying about [__] and we keep
covering up [__] and whatever then he
ain't gonna [__] help us and here we
go like this like we've been going for
seven [__] years
he's he's been known to walk behind the
barn fix himself drinks after the stock
Cuts them off
excellent yes
is that true
that I don't know about
that I don't know about I've gone behind
the bar and made my own drinks yes so
you're blacked out you're that
inebriated that you've got no [__]
idea that you're that far gone he goes
behind the bar take the drink away from
him he cannot move in there in the first
place why is he even in that bar in the
first place
the critical you put
you put drink in the bar it's
hypocritical Philip and we care about
this place and we care about you but a
lot of us feel like you don't give a
damn about us
why are you coming in here to put your
your employees in a bad uncomfortable
situation if it was up to me I'd say
Philip you can't drink in here because
if something happens to you take out a
family of four they're coming after me
and my family
and I don't have any money to afford a
lawyer keep me out of jail for the rest
of my life
[Music]
I'm at the Monticello Hotel in Longview
Washington where the staff are
confronting the owner about a drinking
problem if it was up to me I'd say
Philip you can't drink in here because
if something happens to you take out a
family of four they're coming after me
and my family
and I don't have any money to afford a
lawyer to keep me out of jail for the
rest of my life
they are telling you the truth because
they freaking care unfortunately you're
not telling the truth and that's why
this business is struggling this ship is
on a collision course
can I show you something I think you
should all see come with me
[Music]
I think everybody's forgotten what it's
like for guests to stay in this hotel
then April how much is this room 250 a
night Friday and Saturday is 180 the
rest of the week let me show you what
250 gets you at the Monticello and turn
the lights out
you see that this black light shows up
bodily fluids
that's exactly what you're saying I
wouldn't want to lay on that bed where
these mattresses come from the house in
Arizona your house yes wow those two
holes there that's cigarette holes Burns
what's up everybody don't touch this I
was totally grossed out when I seen that
bed it was sickening 250 to sleep in
Phil
oh my God Philips Seaman right there is
everywhere does that make anybody else
feel sick yeah because right now I am
[__] disgusted by this foul polluted
bed
I felt dirty I'm a clean person it was
disgusting I don't know why you're
running a hotel
ripping people off you don't care
for the customers now you don't care for
your staff who'd you care for
I care about my style
the first thing you said to me when I
arrived here Philip what's the problem
staff
they're bleeding the clock
no way
that's what you told me I've got half it
wrote and down at home where I put at
least 100 hours free in here
we will come in an hour two hours early
not punch in and then we will work late
to get what we need to get done
you have an estate to the tune of 10
[__] million dollars and a chef that
was a hundred hours in for nothing
or is he lying he's not lying he's here
all the time
I'm surprised you guys are here I'm the
only earner for my family and
I make 500 bucks every two weeks
they're [__] crazy
[Music]
and you rock up here with a plate with
Hotel Hell
what the [__] is going on
these guys are your bread and butter
your [__] backbone but they're
terrified to tell you the truth she'll
keep on cutting corners
and humiliating them because they're the
problem the fact that it's not busy look
within it starts from the [__] top
amen yeah
could you just excuse me for leaving
here on my own but Philip thank you
now can you [__] your man up I don't
have all the answers Gordon I'm trying
give me one [__] answer give me
something the abusing your staff what
kind of message does it send to them
when you fill the car part with classic
cars and they're [__] struggling
drink is fair but I think it's fair
enough no
because they deserve better
of course why are you doing it
I don't have an answer for that I don't
know why I'm doing that
leave me alone get the [__] out of here
[Music]
man that was rough sleeping in a tub is
bloody uncomfortable but it certainly
beats sleeping on that filthy mattress
[Music]
the staff have been as honest as they
can be but they're all afraid of losing
their jobs both you come with me please
it's time Philip and ginger heard from
the people who aren't afraid to tell
them the truth good morning everybody
thank you so much for coming
your guests I'm going to give you some
honest feedback
that room was dirty it looked like an
animal was killed and drug out the room
I mean the stain goes down the hall
there's no thought to the guest
experience at all wow you feel like you
threw your money down the drain
pointed to know that I couldn't stay in
a piece of history and got sent over to
a motel I was shocked at the decor that
I saw it was just hideous
it was brutal to hear that many guests
complain about a one-night experience in
the hotel
it actually scares you away when you see
the Marquis that says there's a ladies
night and hiring part-time housekeepers
you don't want to advertise that you're
short on housekeeping
whose stupid idea was it's advertised
for a part-time housekeeper and I guess
it's my idea I'll take the
responsibility thank you
can I ask you all one question would you
come back and stay here please raise
your hands no never never
I appreciate your honesty thank you
thanks
[Music]
you heard what the guests had to say
yeah I did do me a favor spend a couple
of minutes here looking at what you've
inherited and ask yourself do you really
want it enough
do you really care enough
yes I do care
I don't think you do
owner Philip and general manager Ginger
have just found out what the guests
really think about the Monticello Hotel
would you come back and stay here no
never
I think Ginger has finally realized how
much Philip's drinking is hurting the
hotel
and now she's asked to speak to me alone
to my children and they've all talked to
him
but it hasn't been any good
and it's getting worse the stress on my
end has been worthy at is he driving is
he gonna kill somebody is he going to
kill himself
I just wish you told me the truth that's
all I am a private person
and this has been very hard
and it's hard to see someone destroy
themselves
I don't even think he realizes how bad
it is it's been a very heavy burden on
me
he's very old it's a terrible disease
he's a no man and you're suffering the
consequences
[Music]
he needs help and that's the truth I'm
gonna persuade him to get treatment
I will do that I want this place to work
okay I think
and I'm sorry
thank you
I'm going to need the staff's help to
get through to Philip
come through guys maybe together we can
break through his denial
I'm gonna get
Philip in now and I need you to get
behind agreeing that he needs help
now it's hard but you're part of this
change and you stand up for what you
feel is right this staff needs him to
show us that he's willing to make a
change I think he needs to become honest
with himself
this
Hotel
is a Breaking Point
and you need help
[Music]
is there anywhere else in this room that
thinks that Philip needs help with his
addiction please raise that hand
[Music]
because each and every one of them care
not just about the hotel but about you
Ginger you know
how bad
the drinking problem is yes I do I pour
out bottles I empty them out down the
sink
because I love him and I hate to see him
destroy himself and that's what it's
been like it's been very hard
if you could see it through our eyes
it's like night and day during the day
you're just you're amazing Phillip you
talk to us with so much respect and
stuff like that and as soon as you start
drinking you can see that huge
difference come over you it's like the
black cloud We Really Care About You
Phillip
I mean we're afraid for you because
you're Rock Bottom isn't going to be
like most because you have the money to
air way out you have the money to do
what you do your Rock Bottom is going to
be very serious it's either going to
kill you or kill somebody else I don't
want to see you die and I don't want to
see you in trouble and hurt somebody
you're very important you're worth
getting clean you're so worth it okay
Philip will you get help
and I'll keep on hiding this I don't
know what you want me to say Gordon what
about what you want to say
I'm not saying anything
[Music]
we're done
if the entire staff can't get through to
Philip maybe speaking to Malone will
help change his mind he's got to get
help otherwise this place doesn't stand
a chance
when are you gonna snap inside and say
[__]
I'm hitting rock bottom I've been in
this position for the past several years
I'm sorry to hear that don't get upset
huh don't get upset
it's all part of it so what you want to
do for
[Music]
are you ready to get help
please
I promise you I'm definitely going
oh my family for my staff I'm going into
treatment
appreciate that come here it's time
some things in life are more important
than business and I'm glad Philip has
realized he has to put his health first
and sort out his problems
coming up
welcome to the new and improved
Monticello Hotel
[Music]
changes in the air at the Monticello
Hotel so overnight my design team gave
the hotel the makeover it truly deserves
good morning good morning welcome to the
new and improved Monticello Hotel
before we go inside
I want you to notice something
that Dreadful Motel sign
has disappeared
when people want to make a booking you
can offer them a choice of the modern
Annex or the Historic Hotel and that
will be a lot easier because I've opened
up four new Suites for guests doubling
the number of rooms in this Historic
Hotel oh yes
let's go guys
I have butterflies I am so excited to
walk in that hotel I'm jumping ladies
welcome to New Suite isn't it beautiful
wow I love it oh my God
beautiful room they should be used for
guests not storage
never my wildest dreams did I think our
storage unit could end up looking like
this are you ready to see the bedroom
that's so cool I don't I don't have
words gone is all that secondhand
furniture replaced by a comfortable bed
with luxurious Linens now we have
something to be proud of I mean the
place is absolutely gorgeous
stunning new furniture beautiful Linens
and beds for all your Suites very classy
it's mind-blowing what Gordon has done
is just phenomenal what do you think
I think that this is a room that I can
be proud to send my guests to Oh My
Goodness Me wonderful they're never
going to want to leave
now I'd like to show you my room oh my
God
this is amazing for me the stunning
interior
matches the Majestic exterior now you
look on the outside you think this is
exactly the kind of feel you want inside
have a good look at the bedroom this one
you gotta love oh boy oh
I'm the best as you know it's full of
stains now look that beautiful bed
that's what you call a proper king size
bed oh wow it was our best room before
and now it's the best room in town
beautiful guys
the potential here
is phenomenal it's the heart of the town
again and something to be proud of
oh excuse me
welcome to Monticello stunning new room
service oh wow how can a hotel of this
standard not have a small Dynamic room
service menu increases the turnover I'll
never check but more importantly guess
they actually longer to know the food's
that good in the room as well
now get yourselves a plate and start
tasting oh wow this is so good those are
rotten potatoes yeah there's nothing
like fresh salmon that food was amazing
I can't recall the last time I tasted
food so fresh
I think it's going to be a real bonus
enjoy the rest of the food we've got a
big big night ahead of us it's a really
nice menu I think it's going to bring
the revenue higher this is exactly
exactly what we needed this is
sensational
it's not just room service I reinvented
the menu for the restaurant too using
the best local ingredients I'm confident
the combination of great food and great
rooms will encourage a whole new
generation to come here that's getting
medium in there it needs about another
minute or two then we'll pump that one
out okay the difference between the
Frozen and the food we're getting now
night and day there is it's
undescribable for The Taste the
presentation it's awesome keep cooking
with fresh ingredients I will okay and
remember this the day a kitchen can't be
bothered to boil a [__] egg yeah get
out of there okay you're better than
that yes sir good job thank you yeah
well done thank you are you checking in
yes oh can I get your name uh you're
staying in one of our new sweets I can't
wait for people to see these rooms oh
wow and I'm ecstatic I'm gonna have to
send so many less guests out to the
motel this is what I had hoped for
although the guests are delighted with
the changes it looks like Chef Dan has a
problem quick word Oh no you're leaving
the Monticello's relaunch is going
brilliantly nice to see you Gordon you
okay
but Chef Dan has just pulled me aside
take a seat
nine years clean this over well that's
phenomenal well done so I would love to
be a sponsor Phillips sponsor if he
would have me be a sponsor once he gets
out he's going to need somebody by his
side that's an amazing commitment
it's a real big responsibility to be a
field sponsor but it's one I'm willing
to take on get our owner on the right
track yeah good job thank you
it's going to be a challenging Journey
for Philip but with all the support he
has from Ginger only staff I'm hoping
he'll be able to stay away from alcohol
so when you get out of treatment you're
gonna need a sponsor somebody take your
meetings so nine years clean this over
if you want I offer
thank you John all right I appreciate
that sounds good it does now with new
life breathe into the Monticello it's
time for me to go
both you
take care of yourselves okay good luck
thank you sir seriously good luck oh
dear next time I see you
give me a change man oh yes I will one
more thing before I go okay what makes
this place
very special it's not just the historic
building in its 90th year for me it's
the staff so
just so you don't forget it here we are
a new plaque wonderful and the employers
of the month this month are entire staff
and you need to do more than just
recognize how good they are you need to
pay them properly yeah Ramsey did a
wonderful job the hotel is flowing in
the right direction because they do have
a good crew to turn the ship back around
and make it Thrive and I'm going to seek
help
for my drinking thank you Jordan
wow what a place
I really hope Philip keeps his promises
time will tell
since my visit to the Monticello hotel
bookings have gone up this is really
nice
and with all the new Revenue coming in
the staff are working with a new sense
of enthusiasm because Philip is finally
paying them properly for all the hours
they've put in Jordan I want to thank
you for what you did you saved 50
people's jobs and their livelihoods and
their families
and Philip is booked into a treatment
program which starts next week all I can
say is for Gordon is God bless you and
thank you